hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen and today we are going to
the movies now when I heard that another
vegan Netflix documentary had surfaced I
immediately kind of rolled my eyes and
thought it would be just like what the
health but after hearing a ton of really
positive reviews and having a lot of
people directly ask me to review it I
knew it was really time that I had to
give it a watch now before I get started
reviewing the movie I want to start off
by saying I was actually pleasantly
surprised with the film and overall I
think it was really well done while I'm
not personally vegan I do think the
research is very clear that we can all
benefit from incorporating more plants
into our diet having said that it's not
a perfect documentary so I'm going to
talk a little bit about both sides now
before I get started I want to get my
general disclosure that the information
you're about to see is for education and
entertainment purposes only and you
could always take advice from a
healthcare team for your unique case now
if you haven't watched the documentary
here's a little overview on game
changers game changers is a vegan
documentary that was released in late
2009 teen it follows James Wilks who's a
UFC fighter and a military combat
fighting trainer a few years ago James
experienced a terrible knee injury but
led him to having to take off many
months from fighting to recover after
reviewing hundreds of research studies
during this time off James Samuel upon a
study about the gladiator cemetery in
which a total of 22 gladiator skeletons
were analyzed sidenote the movie does
say there were 68 skeletons 31 of which
were non gladiators but I digress now
what the researchers found was that
these men had tremendous bone mineral
density and strength after analyzing
their bones the researchers found that
these men had really high levels of
strontium suggesting that they ate a
primarily plant-based diet
note that the authors did say that the
gladiators were not vegan and did
consume some animal products but that
they ate mainly plants this is
apparently the study that inspired James
to turn to a vegan diet an effort to
speed up his healing and improve his
overall health so game-changers follows
James's journey to healing and also
checks in on other stories of other
athletes who follow a purely plant-based
diet so now that you have a rough idea
on game changers we're gonna do this in
two parts
starting with what I
liked about this video so stay tuned at
spirt to when i'll be unpacking what i
didn't like so much so first let's talk
about some of the claims in the video
that were true number one that
plant-based diets are good for your
health now we know from ample research
and i'll leave some links in the
description below that plant-based diets
definitely improve heart health decrease
the risk of mortality and lower the risk
of other diseases for example and here's
to a plant-based diet is linked to a 19
percent and 11 percent lower risk of
cardiovascular disease mortality and all
cause mortality respectively it's also
linked to a high intake of nutrients
like vitamins A and C folate potassium
iron and polyunsaturated fats a really
great 2018 studies showed that people
pulling a low-carb diet had an 18%
higher risk of death if they replace
their carbs with animal fats and
proteins all those that replace their
carbs with plant fats and proteins saw
an 18% decrease in the risk of death so
this really drives in the importance of
the source of protein fat and carbs that
we're getting in the diet and just like
the documentary talks about the research
is pretty clear that incorporating more
plants into our diet has tremendously
positive effects on our overall health
another claim that they make in defense
of a plant-based diet is that we cannot
produce vitamin C so the documentary
looks kind of at our Paleolithic
ancestors and determines that plant
foods were actually more important than
we may have realized one of the quotes
that stood out to me and I think may be
surprising to people is that we have
longer digestive tracts and carnivores
and this allows you must have digest
plants and fibers that require a longer
processing time we also lack the ability
to produce our own vitamin C so this
indicates how reliant upon plants we
actually are so this little factoid is
actually quite true during the time of
caveman you know these people were not
as lucky as us to have an abundance of
different types of foods at their
disposal so they ate whatever whenever
that food was available sometimes that
may have meant eating just plants for a
long period of time and other times when
the hunting was really good it was meat
for days before it spoiled now as James
mentions humans do have different
digestive tracts and other mammals and
I'll touch more about that later but
compared to strict carnivores we have a
much better
ability to digest carbohydrates and
plant-based materials this is due to
many reasons but one example is that
humans have higher levels of glucose
transporters and as a result typically
consume a much higher carbohydrate to
protein ratio compared to meat-eating
carnivores James also touches on the
importance of vitamin C as a marker of
our ancestral diet history since vitamin
C comes from plants he's totally right
that plants are an excellent source of
vitamin C and that we can't produce our
own vitamin C he's also right that we
are highly dependent on plants to get
these nutrients although to be fair I
would hope there are very few non vegans
that could deny this fact maybe some of
our carnivore friends but vitamin C is
important for so many functions like
collagen synthesis non heme iron
absorption and supporting the immune
system so yeah James you are totally
right we need to be eating vitamin C
rich foods whether or not a non vegan
can't get enough I don't see is not
something I would definitely agree with
but I'll get to my criticism later the
other thing that I feel well aligned
with whether you're a vegan or not is
that a lot of us could probably benefit
from a b12 supplement so what James is
talking about in the scene is that the
one thing that didn't fit with this idea
that our bodies are not built for an
animal-based diet is b12 and that he's
always been told that b12 comes solely
from animal products but what he's
uncovered is that b12 isn't actually
made by the animals it's made by
bacteria that the animals consume in
their soil in water so just like with
protein animals are kind of like the
middlemen and he states that before
industrial farming farm animals and
humans could get b12 from eating bits of
dirt on plant foods or by drinking water
but now because of pesticides
antibiotics and chlorine etc it kills
the bacteria and for that reason even
farm animals have to be given b12
supplements and then he states a
research study that found that 39% of
people who were tested including
meat-eaters were low and b12 james's
bottom line in all this is that a lot of
us whether or not we eat animal foods
could probably benefit from taking a b12
supplement now for this clean I have
both positive and negative things to say
but to keep things organized I'll just
say them both here and then we can
bigger issues and my critique video but
let's start with the positive so James
is definitely right that most people can
adequately thrive off of a plant-based
diet because our body is able to produce
necessary vitamins and minerals or we're
able to get them through plant-based
foods it's also true that vitamin b12 is
really the only exception as our body
just does not produce high amounts of it
and there are really no good plant-based
sources except maybe nutritional yeast
b12 however is crucial to our health for
so many reasons it helps make DNA
supports our metabolism keeps our
nervous system functioning increases
blood cell development and so much more
now most people get vitamin b12 through
animal sources through supplements or
b12 injections and we don't usually
recommend supplements or injections
unless there's like still a deficiency
with eating food sources of b12 or if a
person follows a predominantly
plant-based diet so food sources of
vitamin b12 include things like fish
eggs cheese beef pork chicken milk and
other dairy products and again the only
plant-based source of b12 is nutritional
yeast you can also get vitamin b12 from
fortified cereals and grains so it is
also a really great option for people
who are avoiding animal products now
while b12 deficiency is common it's
probably less so than what they list in
this film from the data that I've looked
at it's closer to about 15% although it
does definitely depend on the population
you're analyzing those who are at an
increased risk of deficiency include the
elderly those with malabsorption issues
like Crohn's disease or celiac disease
people with pernicious anaemia and of
course vegetarians and vegans now James
is also correct to suggest that b12 is
produced by bacteria but here is where
he's wrong b12 is produced by bacteria
and then accumulates in animal tissues
however that doesn't mean that animals
being the middleman is necessarily a bad
thing
for example cows have a four chambered
stomach that contain b12 synthesizing
bacteria essentially these bacteria
produced b12 in the cow's stomach and
then this is absorbed and stored in the
liver muscles or is secreted into their
milk James says that the best way to get
b12 is through supplements and I would
have to disagree
in a recent 2009
review in the frontiers of nutrition
researchers concluded that milk was
associated with the highest levels of
b12 followed by animal meats and cheeses
they also know that those who consumed a
vegan or plant-based diet had much lower
levels of b12 compared to omnivores
in fact most omnivores had sufficient
levels again not everyone who follows an
omnivore diet has adequate levels of b12
and in that case a supplement is
definitely required but if you follow a
vegan or vegetarian diet I would
definitely suggest getting your levels
tested regularly and speaking to your
doctor about a good b12 supplement I'm
gonna leave one of my favorites in the
link below so you can check that out as
well okay so now let's dive into some
other things that I really loved about
this film number one dispelling a long
history of gender stereotypes so the
film points out a very long history in
marketing that's associated manliness or
manhood with meat one of my favorite
parts of this film is the genuine effort
to dispel all the irrational gender
stereotypes surrounding what we eat for
decades we have seen commercials that
promote meat as the ultimate fuel for
men and salads for women in order to be
a man you need to eat meat in order to
be a good woman you need to eat salad
this gendering of foods is truly
damaging to our health and well-being
so I feel like game changers does a
fantastic job with convincing its
viewers that men can still be manly and
follow a plant-based diet they show tons
and tons of clips or at the movie of
strong muscly men that claim to eat a
vegan diet from a world-record-holding
strong man to a heavyweight boxer this
documentary does a really great job at
debunking the theory than order to be
strong you have to eat meat they also
highlight another sexualized taboo topic
men's sexual performance okay so here we
see dr. Aaron Spitz author of the penis
book do an experiment on three young men
essentially the three men were fed
animal-based burritos one night and then
a plant-based burrito the second night
both nights the men were connected to
monitors that tested the intensity and
length of erections that naturally would
occur over the night they found that the
plant-based burritos led to upwards of a
13.5 4% increase
and penis girth during the erection and
up to four hundred and seventy seven
percent increase in erection minutes
granted this is not a scientifically
validated study and fortunately the
doctor mentions this but it really does
convince these three guys that
plant-based foods are not going to
somehow take away their manhood finally
on the topic of gender stereotypes they
drive in the fact that plant-based soy
proteins like tofu will not increase
estrogen levels and they do a really
great job at explaining the science
behind this as well we know from
research that the consumption of soy
proteins does not alter men's
testosterone levels this was shown in a
robust 2010 meta-analysis as well as a
recent 2017 study in 47 college men in
which there was no major differences in
testosterone or estrogen levels after
consuming whey protein soy protein or a
placebo so kudos to this another thing
that I really liked about this
documentary was there was less
fear-mongering and more science unlike
in what the health this documentary
limited it's biased fear-mongering
and really just lay down the research I
mean yes there was still some occasional
out there claims such as the connection
between tobacco and meat and the
experiments were definitely not always
high-quality or reliable but I didn't
feel threatened by the end of it the
same way I did
after watching other shocking entries
one of the biggest problems with
documentaries is their reliance on
attention-grabbing claims it's really
really boring to listen to a person say
even moderation so a lot of producers
cherry-pick data to get people talking
am I happy with all of the research that
they used no definitely not but we will
get to that momentarily another thing
that I liked was the transparency in
research one issue with documentaries is
their true lack of transparency they'll
take a study make their own conclusions
and very rarely will they actually share
which research study they're talking
about but game-changers actually does a
really good job listing each research
study that they used and even went so
far as to show us visuals from the
research studied which included their
names their journals and authors in my
opinion the more transparency
the less there is to hide and it really
helps a critical thinker like me buy
into some of their points another thing
that I actually appreciated about this
film was their moderate approach to
transitioning to a plant-based diet
sometimes it's hard to watch these
shocking entries because they always
tend to be really extreme and pushy
coming from experience I believe it's
hard to convince someone to change their
lifestyle that they become accustomed to
their entire life so telling someone to
just go eat vegan honestly doesn't
really help so for example one of the
athletes in the film said something like
people have this idea in their head that
if they're gonna do something it's an
all-or-nothing approach and that's not
the case at all and she's right and all
or nothing approach is very hard for
people if you just straight-up tell
somebody hey you need to stop eating
meat and dairy products today when they
actually really like to eat meat and
dairy products and that's something that
they've always had you might lose them
almost immediately instead the
documentary really emphasizes the
importance of a vegan diet but also
brings to light the benefits of just
making small changes over time Arnold
said it best hey why don't you just try
once a week just chill it with the meat
this type of balanced reasonable
approach is something that I also
recommend people you don't have to get
rid of all the animals to make a
difference slowly transitioning to more
plants will tend to just crowd out some
of the animal products in your diet so
if all or nothing doesn't work for you
as it doesn't always work for me some is
really a great place to start but alas
when I did some real digging I uncovered
a few problematic claims and tactics
number one was the comparison of a
peanut butter sandwich to beef or eggs
in terms of protein quality and quantity
it just doesn't perfectly hold up so in
one of the scenes they talked about how
one cup of cooked lentils or a peanut
butter sandwich has as much protein as a
three ounce serving of beef or three
large eggs and then they talked about
the quality of the protein they state
that proteins are strings of amino acids
and there's some amino acids that our
bodies can't make true those are the
essential amino acids so we have to get
them from food and one of the arguments
about animal-based proteins being
superior is that
plant-based proteins are not complete so
you're not gonna get all of those
essential amino acids but that is a
fallacy as well now I love peanut butter
and I eat it several times a week but
let's take a look at how some of these
stack up now one large egg has six grams
of protein so that there's 18 grams of
protein of three eggs a three ounce
steak has around 17 to 21 grams of
protein if we assume that a peanut
butter sandwich has two pieces of bread
and two tablespoons of natural peanut
butter then two pieces of bread has
around eight grams of protein and 2
tablespoons of natural peanut butter has
around 9 grams of protein for a total of
17 grams of protein in the sandwich so
yes it is around the same amount as eggs
and a little bit less than steak here's
the thing though this peanut butter
sandwich has around 370 calories the
steak has around 113 calories and the
eggs have about 215 although having a
peanut butter sandwich is totally
awesome we can't ignore the fact that
you have to have almost twice the amount
of calories just to meet the protein
needs through plants at least for this
example that they're given so this is
usually the case for a lot of
plant-based proteins for example to get
20 grams of proteins from almonds you'd
need 2/3 of a cup which equals about 542
calories again not dissing plant-based
proteins love them love almonds but if
we look at the protein on a gram per
calorie basis some options are more
efficient than others another thing to
keep in mind is that plant-based
proteins tend to have lower
bioavailability compared to animal
proteins what's more they're not always
a complete source of all essential amino
acids despite what dr. Loomis says in
the film with that being said you can
totally get enough essential amino acids
from plant-based foods you just have to
make sure that you're getting different
sources of plants so that you cover all
of your amino acid bases finally in the
instance of sports nutrition
specifically you probably wouldn't want
to have a peanut butter sandwich after a
hard workout because the fat will slow
down the uptake of the protein ideally
we actually want lower fat meals with a
combination of carbs and protein after
workout for this specific reason
next is some of the flaws in the burrito
centrifuge experiment alright so at
first glance physics
is shocking and so interesting also it
makes me want a burrito like stat
however let's really dive into this
experiment now first to be clear this is
not a controlled study and there are
tons of flaws from the get-go first of
all you have an NFL player that's been
vegan for many years then you have NFL
players that are adamant about their
processed food so right away you don't
have apples to apples comparison what
would be a better comparison is if you
had a vegan an omnivore that eats
minimally processed food and then
another person who eats a lot of
processed food even that would be rife
with compounders but still it's at least
a little bit more realistic also we
don't have an apples to apples
comparison with the burritos the vegan
burrito uses black beans which are high
in carbs and protein but very low in fat
the meat burritos are much higher in fat
content this is a problem because after
eating the food fats are packaged into
chylomicrons and then enter into the
blood
so yes eating a high fat meal you're
gonna see higher amounts of fat
accumulate into the blood furthermore
research shows that certain types of low
fat lean animal products are linked with
better and athelia function so while
this experiment is definitely
eye-opening for people who eat a lot of
high fat processed food it's not a good
comparison for those who have a more
whole food balanced diet and who consume
lean meats or poultry or seafood in
moderation also I just want to point out
that it's really convenient that a lot
of these documentaries denounce evidence
or research that's being funded by
animal or dairy industries but then to
turn around and to use evidence that has
been sponsored by plant-based industries
to support their claims it's
hypocritical to support one type of
research over the other we either accept
it all as evidence or we leave it all on
the floor we cannot pick or choose so
for example this experiment was inspired
by a study that was funded by Hass
avocados that found that triglyceride
levels did not increase when you added
some avocado to a burger compared to
just eating the burger as is also just
want to mention that that study had 11
subjects now I love love love
avocados and I also think that research
studies can be done very well even if
they're sponsored I don't have an issue
with it as long as it's still really
good research which I mean 11
participants mmm not so much but
ultimately it's only fair that if we're
gonna dismiss research study being
funded by meat and dairy we probably
should not be using funded studies by
plant-based industries as a rebuttal
okay so next thing I want to discuss and
unpacked is this claim that animals are
jacked on plant-based proteins so that
we ultimately should be to humans have
different digestive systems than any
other animal
cows have a four chambered stomach which
allows them to properly digest grass and
extract a higher amount of amino acids
from the grass humans on the other hand
do not have the ability to digest grass
therefore arguing that we should be able
to build muscle off of plants using that
as an example just doesn't really make
sense to me also we're not gorillas
either gorillas have a larger colon than
humans have allowing them to break down
plants significantly better this is also
why gorillas can digest a lot of stems
and fibrous plants but humans can't or
at least we need to like cook them down
or pulverize them gorillas also eat
upwards of 40 pounds of food per day
that would be a really big deal so again
it's not an apples to apples comparison
to think of us like other animals I also
want to touch on how the film
consistently compares processed animal
foods to whole plant foods if you notice
in the film they seem to always compare
super high-fat highly processed meats to
whole unprocessed plant food a good
example is when they meet with the Miami
Dolphin players and they talk about how
much they love fried chicken and they
don't ever plan to stop eating out but
fried chicken is literally dipped in a
bath of fat to be cooked so no this is
not gonna be the healthiest choice to
choose every single day on the other
hand a chicken breast is quite low in
fat and is a good source of quality
protein and then there's Arnold's diet
so Arnold talks about how he was eating
ten to fifteen eggs a day and 250 grams
of protein every single day that's
pretty extreme and then he talks about
how when he adopted a plant-based diet
his cholesterol levels went down
yeah obviously when you've cut out 15
eggs a day
I wouldn't expect or recommend anyone to
be loading up on animal products like
that what the film doesn't really
adequately acknowledge was that super
highly processed plant foods aren't
really necessarily inherently healthy
either so for example in a 2017 research
study of seventy three thousand seven
hundred and ten women researchers found
that a whole food plant-based diet was
linked to a 25% decreased risk and
coronary heart disease on the contrary a
processed plant-based diet led to a 32%
increased risk of coronary heart disease
this just goes to show that the form the
food comes in matters a lot maybe even
more so than whether or not it's
plant-based well I understand that
they're of course trying to sell the
idea that plant-based foods can taste
delicious there also may be perhaps
unknowingly selling the idea that overly
processed vegan foods are still really
healthy choices just because they're
vegan
thanks to really good marketing vegan
foods like gluten-free foods tend to
have a real health halo going on but our
copycat vegan Big Macs or vegan cookies
really the best option to eat every
single day personally speaking just from
a nutritional perspective if this was
the alternative I would we rather see
somebody have a chicken salad and a
yogurt parfait
bottom line vegan doesn't necessarily
mean it's healthy and then finally
there's the claim that milk lowers
testosterone in men so in the
documentary they bring up a particular
study and they suggest the findings were
that drinking a cup of cow's milk can
increase a male's estrin level by 26% in
just one hour while dropping their
testosterone levels by 18 percent the
research that they're quoting is
absolutely good research however they
definitely lose my trust when they start
cherry-picking the data problem is this
research study they looked at had seven
men six prepubescent children and five
women and even though that's already a
really super small sample size they only
talked about the seven men making the
sample size even smaller so in those
seven men that were studied
Astrid and secretion temporarily
increased while testosterone secretion
temporarily
decreased what Jane's fails to mention
was that these levels only change
temporarily and peaked around one hour
after that it just went back to normal
Jane's words it a little bit differently
by saying drinking a cup of cow's milk
can increase the male's Estrin levels by
26% in one hour while dropping their
testosterone levels by 18% so this
suggests that in just an hour it
increases to that much with no mention
of it ever going back down again I'm not
suggesting that these hormonal changes
are a good thing and it's totally your
prerogative to eat whatever you feel
comfortable with but not discussing the
full effect seems a little bit
misleading I do think we need more
context okay so now let's talk about
some of my other grievances with the
film and what I didn't love about it
generally speaking number one the
filmmakers had a clear vegan agenda and
I'm not so sure that that is always so
well cited in a lot of these consumer
entertainment films just like any type
of documentary game-changers had a clear
agenda to get you to follow a vegan diet
it would be the same for you know any
keto or paleo or any other documentary
but the people who make these
documentaries are making them for a
reason and it's their job to make their
case as compelling as possible well I
think that they navigated this pretty
well especially compared to with some
other shocking entries out there I think
it would have been really a nice idea to
emphasize their own personal bias all of
the people who spoke on the film were
either predominantly or completely
plant-based so obviously there's gonna
be a little bit of bias going on now
let's be clear it's impossible to be
completely Switzerland even though you
know I'm trying but we all have our own
unique experiences that really put a
certain bias lens on us however it's
really my opinion that taking the time
to reflect on our biases can help us
make sure that it doesn't affect our
professional opinions that's like that I
have been trying to do here at Abby's
kitchen and I think I would have trusted
the content even more had I seen that
happening if they wanted to appear more
unbiased they really should have
included both sides but instead they
only spoke to people who followed a
plant-based diet or who advocated for a
plant-based diet again it's not as
biases I've seen in other documentary so
I totally applaud that but I still think
it's something that they could have
improved on and still made really really
strong points if not stronger because in
my opinion the science in itself is
compelling enough let the science speak
for itself there were also quite a few
conflicts of interest and biases that
were not mentioned so like I said the
film had doctors experts and athletes
that already follow a plant-based diet
so there is an inherent bias there but
furthermore a lot of the people that
they interviewed had unmentioned
conflicts of interest which I really
don't love so like James Cameron is of
course the filmmaker of movies like
Titanic and Avatar but he's also the
founder and CEO of verdiant foods which
is a vegan pea protein company dr. Aaron
Spitz who's the author of the penis book
which is also a plant-based book dr.
Robert Vogel who's the author of the
Pritikin edge another plant-based book
dr. James Loomis owner of a plant-based
meal planning service dr. Ornish author
of undo it and seller of vegan retreats
and online programs etc etc etc also
when you use celebrities like Arnold
Schwarzenegger to promote a lifestyle
they obviously will have a huge impact
due to their celebrity card so while
these speakers are experienced and
successful in their careers they really
should list their potential conflicts of
interests if they're gonna try to call
out other professionals and researchers
for theirs honestly I understand why
they'd want to interview and incorporate
a wide range of kind of plant-based
scholars and plant-based supporters it
makes total sense I just like the
transparency number three there was
definitely a lack of professional
representation from my industry the
leaders in nutrition so in the film you
see a number of plant-based doctors and
athletes talking about plant-based
eating but that's about it
they don't interview dieticians who are
the experts in nutrition if you're gonna
talk about nutrition
you should probably always have a
dietician at the table
it's like talking about brain health and
not having a neuroscientist or a
neurologist they're the experts
unfortunately there was only one
registered dietician in the field
and it was one that they convene lead
cherry-picked from the CNN interview in
which the dietitian advocates for meat
consumption so it's kind of
disappointing that the only dietitian
that they show is painted as a bit of a
villain when there is a lot a lot a lot
if not pretty much all dietitians that
I'm aware of are really big supporters
of a predominantly plant-based diet
taking a clip from just one dietitian
and generalizing it for all dietitians
is totally unfair and inaccurate so
while the dietitian is correct in saying
that we can't establish a
cause-and-effect relationship between
meat and cancer I think that I can speak
for a lot of dietitians here when I say
that we would all benefit from reducing
our meat consumption and including more
plant-based foods in our diet I think we
personally need to meet people where
they are though and that may mean making
leaner choices or lower sodium choices
or swapping out one meat meal a week
with a plant-based protein etc I've been
pretty clear on my personal belief that
all foods can fit and then it really
does not need to be an all-or-nothing
approach on a side note I recently
watched an interview with James in which
he said that while they probably could
have had more dieticians in the film the
Academy of Nutrition and Dietetics is
sponsored by the meat and dairy industry
okay so even though I'm Canadian and I'm
part of a totally different professional
body I want to make something clear we
are not sponsored or controlled by any
food industry I've spoken about my own
personal involvement in my sponsorship
video here and I agree that's
unfortunate that any food industry has
been sponsoring conferences or events I
don't like that at all but I also know
that learning opportunities like
conferences require money and while I'm
going way off course here I will note
that even at conferences I've been to
where let's say a meat or dairy industry
has signed on as a sponsor I've never
seen an impact the content or learning
that tends to take place and I've been
to lots of great webinars and keynotes
about the benefits of plant-based eating
so for the same reasons I don't like
that doctor's conferences are sponsored
by pharmaceutical companies I get that
it feels icky but I also know that all
of us dietitians are still really
capable of evaluating the research and
making balanced realistic
recommendations for our clients based on
it okay so issue number four
that I just felt there was too much of a
reliance on personal anecdotes
now while personal stories are super
helpful and give examples of the
benefits of the plant-based diet they
aren't really science sure the athletes
say that they feel better and they
probably did but we can't just use their
experience of solid evidence in fact a
lot of their claims regarding sports
performance lack any concrete evidence
or require way more actual real research
before any conclusions can be made
although I'm super happy that these
people found success on a plant-based
diet there are also many arguably even
more successful athletes that follow an
omnivorous diet so highlighting that hey
veganism and athleticism are not
mutually exclusive experience is great
and so important it doesn't negate the
idea that success as an athlete is also
possible following an omnivore diet and
yet because we don't see that experience
or any solid research comparing these we
don't really see that or know that if we
become a too reliant on personal
anecdotes then we're opening up a whole
crazy can of worms where we can make any
claim that we want regarding health and
believe it's true could you imagine if
someone said I started eating two bags
of gummy bears a day and I felt better
and decided that that was enough to
promote a gummy bear diet I know that
it's an extreme example but I see this
stuff happening all the time and it's
like literally why I have a job so on
that note I want to give my overall
conclusion on game-changers I actually
give this film a positive rating I have
tried to be super balanced and critical
here so I hope you can see that while I
fully support plant-based diets it
doesn't mean I'm always fern on
evidence-based ways of promoting them
yes I think their use of some of the
research is faulty
but they do bring up a lot of really
important points and I also think it's
kind of inspiring it definitely helps
dispel the myth that a vegan diet and
athleticism are mutually exclusive I
also think even for us non athletes it
serves a really good reminder that we
would all benefit from a plant-based
diet even if that means just introducing
more plants to our diet in general keep
in mind that you know nutrition science
is extremely complicated
it's not black and white if it was I
mean we'd all be living into our
hundreds trying to jam in nutrition
science into an hour-and-a-half
documentary is nearly impossible so I
commend game-changers for the effort
that they made here and while there are
quite a few flaws in the film I mean
like all films their overall message of
eating more plants is something that I
can totally get on board with so guys I
would love to know if you have watched
game changers what did you like what did
you think of it let me know in the
comments don't forget to subscribe give
this video the thumbs up if you liked my
critical balanced review and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]